JUDSON, AND HAPPY NEW YEAR AS
WELL.
AT >> Jason: HOUSE DEMOCRATS
ARE ACCUSING PRESIDENT TRUMP OF
ABUSE OF POWER, AND THE
OBSTRUCTION OF CONGRESS.
IS THAT NOT EXACTLY WHEN
NANCY PELOSI IS DOING BY
REFUSING TO SEND IMPEACHMENT
ARTICLES TO THE UNITED STATES
SENATE?
DEMOCRATS FROM THE START HAVE
BEEN SAYING THIS HAD TO BE DONE
IMMEDIATELY.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
SUPPOSED TO DO HORRIBLE DANGER
TO OUR COUNTRY, OUR VALUES, OUR
PEOPLE, AND OUR REPUTATION.
>> THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY CLOSES A
CLEAR AND PRESENT DANGER TO OUR
COUNTRY AND TO THE WORLD.
>> THE UKRAINE ALLEGATION AS
HEAD AND SHOULDERS ONE OF THE
MOST SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS THAT WE
HAVE SEEN.
>> THE TIMING HAS REALLY DRIVEN
BY THE URGENCY.
>> Jason: JOINING ME NOW IS
TOM FITTON, THE PRESIDENT OF
JUDICIAL WATCH.
ALONG WITH THE JOHN EASEMENT,
CLAREMONT INSTITUTION SENIOR AND
CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR.
IF I WANT TO START WITH YOU
BECAUSE YOU'RE THE ONE THAT
POINTED OUT THE WARNING IN THE
REVOLUTION PASSED IN THE HOUSE.
OF THE HOUSE REVOLUTION NUMBER
55 AND IT'S AS IF PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES IS IMPEACHED
FOR HIGH CRIMES AND DISMAY
MISDEMEANORS, THE FOLLOWING
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT, HE
EXHIBITED IT TO THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
NOW, JOHN, DOES NOT MEAN EXACTLY
WHAT IT SAYS?
THE DEMOCRATS WROTE THE ARTICLES
AND THEY ARE SOLELY THE ONES
THAT PASS THEM AND THEY ARE NOT
ABIDING BY THEM, CORRECT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, AND THEY SEEM
TO THINK IF SHE WERE TO HAVE
ANOTHER VOTE THAT SAYS DON'T
SEND THEM OVER TO THE SENATE SHE
WOULD PROBABLY GET THE MAJORITY
ON THAT AS WELL.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE THE VOTE,
WE CAN DEEM IT AS HAVING THE
ACCOMPLISHMENT LIKE THEY PULLED
BACK WITH THE OBAMACARE
LEGISLATION NEARLY A DECADE AGO.
NO, THEY HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES OPERATES BY
MAJORITY VOTE AS A BODY.
IF NO INDIVIDUAL MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES HAS ANY
POWER DIFFERENT THAN OTHER
MEMBERS AND EVEN THE SPEAKER.
WHEN THEY PASSED A RESOLUTION
THAT SAYS IT SHALL BE EXHIBITED
TO THE SENATES, THAT'S THE LAW.
THERE IS NO FURTHER ACTION
NECESSARY.
WE ARE IN UNCHARTED TERRITORY
BUT QUITE FRANKLY, IF I'M
SENATOR McCONNELL, THIS
EXHIBITED TO THE SENATES I READ
IN THE CONGRESSIONAL RECORD THAT
WE'RE ABOUT TO TAKE IT OUT NEXT
WEEK.
>> Jason: I'M THINKING MAY
CURRENTLY
MARRENTLY
MAY ENTLY
MAY BETLY
MAY BE DY
MAY BE DO THAT, BUT THEYHAVE THE
MAY BE DO THAT, BUT THEYHAVE THC
MAY BE DO THAT, BUT THEYHAVE THA
MAY BE DO THAT, BUT THEYHAVE THO
MAY BE DO THAT, BUT THEYHAVE THN
MAY BE DO THAT, BUT THEYHAVE THG
MAY BE DO THAT, BUT THEYHAVE THT
MAY BE DO THAT, BUT THEYHAVE THE
ONSET HERE IN WASHINGTON THEY
WRITE THE ARTICLES AND THEY
PASSED THEM THEMSELVES, WHICH
ARE TAKEN?
US BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
LOSE IN THE SENATES, THEY PUT
OFF THE LAWS EVEN A CHILD IS
ABBREVIATED AND THOUGH STILL GOI
ABBREVIATED AND THOUGH STILL GOG
TO LOSE AND THEY
DON'T WANT TO HAPPEN.
OFFICE LEASING A NEW OPPORTUNITY
AND THROUGH THE ELECTION HAVE
THE PERPETUAL IMPEACHMENT OVER
THE PRESIDENT.
IF THE PROBLEM IS THE
CONSTITUTION --
>> Jason: THAT ALWAYS GETS IN
THE WAY?
LITTLE THING CALLED THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> I CALLED US TO, AND USE THE
ELEMENTS WITH THE IMPEACHMENT
OBVIOUSLY, BASED ON NOTHING AND
SO ABUSING THE RULES AND POWERS
THEY HAVE UNDER THE CONSTITUTION
AND BY IMPEACHING HIM FOR
NOTHING.
IF NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO
OVERTHROW THE SENATE.
THEY WANT TO DO -- IF THEY DON'T
GET THEIR TYPE OF HEARINGS
AGAINST THE PRESIDENTS, THE
TRYING TO BLOW UP THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH AS WELL.
IF I WERE MITCH McCONNELL, I
WOULD SAY WE ARE GOING TO RUN A
TRIAL HERE.
PELOSI CAN ANTICIPATE OR NOT, WE
ARE GOING TO RUN THE TRIAL AND
PRICKLY TO THE DEGREE, IT SHOULD
BE ADAM SCHIFF AND HIS
PROSECUTOR TRIAL.
WHY WOULD YOU REWARD HIM WITH
THE ABUSIVE TRIAL OF THE
PRESIDENT?
>> Jason: JOHN, HOW DOES OF
THE PRESIDENT DUE PROCESS?
THEY BEEN THROWING ALLEGATIONS
AT HIM SINCE DAY ONE.
IT NANCY PELOSI ADMITTED, SHE
FINALLY SAID, WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON IMPEACHMENT FOR MORE THAN TWO
AND A HALF YEARS.
THAT'S IS A LOT.
IF THEY'RE OFF THE RECESS AND
HOW DOES THE PRESIDENT ACTUALLY
GET DUE PROCESS IN THE CASE?
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE VERY
REASONS THE LEGAL COUNSEL HAS
FOR TICKETS, UNDER BOTH
ADMINISTRATIONS, SAYS THE
PRESIDENT CAN BE INDICTED WHILE
HE'S IN OFFICE.
THEY CAN BRING THE TRIAL AGAINST
HIM AND INDICTMENT HANGING OVER
HIS HEAD THAT HE CANNOT
VINDICATE HIMSELF AND IT WOULD
CRUMPLE THE PRESIDENCY OF THE
OFFICE ITSELF.
WHEN NANCY PELOSI IS DOING HERE
IS EXACTLY THE SAME THING.
THE PARALLEL WITH THE FIRST
ARTICLE IMPEACHMENT IS THAT THEY
ARE USING THE POWERS OF THEIR
OFFICE TO TRY TO INVESTIGATE THE
HEAD OF THE OPPOSING POLITICAL
PARTY WHO HAPPENS TO BE DONE IN
1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE, WHAT
THEY ARE DOING IS THE
IMPEACHMENT ITSELF MUCH LESS THE
HOLDING OUT FOR THE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT AND NOT SENDING FOR
THE SENATES.
IT'S THE UTMOST ABUSE OF OFFICE.
HE REALLY IS A TRAVESTY AND IT
SHOWS YOU HOW BLINDLY -- HOW
MUCH BLIND HATE.
THEY HAVE FOR THE PRESIDENT THAT
THEY ARE WILLING TO THROW OFF
EVERY NORM
IN ORDER TO FIND SOME DIRT ON
THE PRESIDENT TO GET HIM OUT OF
OFFICE.
>> Jason: WHAT'S INTERESTING
FOR ME, GOING BACK TO THE PESKY
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTION, I THINK
I SAW DONALD TRUMP JR. PUTS THIS
OUT, WHEN THEN SIMPLY PELOSI IS
ACTUALLY WANTING AS A QUID PRO
QUO.
I WILL SEND YOU OVER IF YOU DO
THIS, IT'S KIND OF IRONIC AND
THE WHOLE THING.
THE CONSTITUTION SAYS IT HAS A
SOUL POWER.
IT IS THE HOUSE HAS THE SOLE
POWER TO MOVE FORWARD ARTICLES
OF IMPEACHMENT AND THE SENATE
HAS THE SOLE POWER.
IF THAT'S THE PROBLEM FOR
NANCY PELOSI, ISN'T IT A
QUESTION MARK >> THAT IS, AND
THAT'S WHAT YOU TRYING THE
IMPEACHMENT OF THE ARTICLES AND
THE TIMING.
THEY IMPEACHMENT AND THEN SENATE
TAKES UP THE TRIAL AND IF I WERE
MITCH McCONNELL, I WOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE THE REALITY AND TAKE
THE CONSTITUTIONAL LIMBO.
OF ALL THE HE NEEDS TO DO IS HIS
JOB, AND HE TWEETED HE MAKES IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR HIM TO TALK
WITH FOREIGN LEADERS AND WE
DON'T WANT THE CONGRESS AND THE
RADICAL FASHION BLOWING UP THE
CONSTITUTION JUST FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES.
IF YOU KNOW, I'VE HALF JOKINGLY
SAID THIS, BUT MITCH McCONNELL
FAMOUSLY, AND CORRECTLY IN MY
VIEW, PUT OFF THE CONFIRMATION
OF MAYOR GARLAND DURING THE
ELECTION YEAR.
IF I THINK THE SENATE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT PUTTING OFF ANY
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL OF THE
PRESIDENT OR DISMISSING IT
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT DOING AN
ELECTION HERE.
>> Jason: THAT WOULD BE
INTERESTING TAKE ON IT.
IF NOW, JOHN, QUICKLY WE'VE ONLY
GOT A FEW SECONDS LEFT, BUT
THERE'S SOME TALK WITH DEMOCRATS
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY DELAY THIS
UNTIL AFTER THE ELECTION AND
THEN WANT TO BRING UP THE SAME
ARTICLES AGAIN IN BETWEEN THE
TIME OF THE ELECTION IN NOVEMBER
AND WHEN THE NEW PRESIDENT OR
THE REELECTION OF DONALD TRUMP
HAPPENS.
OF IS THAT GETTING TO THAT?
>> SO THE RIGHT TO HAVE COUNCIL
PRESIDENT HEARINGS, THE RIGHT TO
CONFRONT WITNESSES AGAINST YOU
AND NOW THROWING IN THE DOUBLE
DEPUTY CLAUSE, AND THE
SCHERMAN-ESQUE BLOKE OF THE
CONSTITUTION NORMS OF CRIMINAL
PROCEDURES.
IF IT'S NOT JUST THE PRESIDENT
IS BEING VICTIMIZED HERE, IT'S T
IS BEING VICTIMIZED HERE, IT'S E
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT ITSELF
THAT'S BEING UNDERMINED.
IT'S A GREAT DETRIMENT ON OUR
ABILITY TO CONDUCT THE
GOVERNMENT BOTH HOME AND ABROAD.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED IN FULL FORCE THAT
THEY REALLY ARE NOT INTERESTED
IN GETTING MUCH DONE.
WHAT YOU THINK'S GOING TO HAPPEN
WHEN THEY ACTUALLY RECONVENE
HERE IN THE 1ST OF JANUARY WAS
BACK >> WE SEE THE HARD-CORE
SENATOR SAY THAT WE ARE GOING TE
SENATOR SAY THAT WE ARE GOING TT
THIS QUICKLY.
PELOSI MAY HAVE OVERREACHED HERE
AND I THINK THERE IS GOING TO BE
SOME TYPE OF TRIAL WHERE THERE'S
GOING TO BE A ADJUDICATION THAT
WILL VINDICATE THE PRESIDENT.
>> Jason: ONLY NANCY PELOSI
YOU KNOW, SHE POSTS UP
EVERYTHING AND FOCUSES ON
EVERYTHING AND I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT